welcome to the man of Recaps this is
Avatar the first movie Welcome to
Pandora a wild beautiful jungle plan
it's filled with natural wonder so
obviously humans are here to strip mine
it Jake Sully is an injured Marine who's
lost the use of his legs and he's
brought in for the Avatar project where
he'll control an alien body of the
Native species the navi this body was
built for Jake's brother a scientist but
because they're identical twins it'll
work with Jake so he's in and now he's a
blue alien cat person and this is
especially exciting for Jake because you
know now he can walk again he joins the
rest of Team Avatar his scientist boss
Sigourney Weaver and his funny co-worker
The Big Bang Theory they Venture forth
to explore Pandora a breathtakingly
beautiful place but with dangerous
wildlife where everything wants to kill
you it's basically space Australia on
his very first day Jake gets separated
he's not gonna survive the night but
what's this a native Navi bust in to
save him she is natiri and at first
thinks Jake is just another dumb human
but the tree wisps seem to like him so
she figures he must be okay she takes
him to her father the chief who wants to
kill him but she stands up for him so
yeah yeah it's exactly Pocahontas back
in his human body Jake meets with the
mean military guy who gives him a secret
mission to infiltrate the navi and learn
everything about him see the humans are
here to mind the super valuable mineral
unobtainium and right under the navi
home tree is where most of it is they
want Jake to find a way to get him to
move peacefully otherwise they're gonna
have to go kick him out and sonatiri
teaches Jake the ways of the Nabi and
Pandora is an absolutely insane place
where you just like jump off of trees
and hope leaves will catch you luckily
Jake is kind of a crazy adrenaline
junkie so he's all about this life
naturally he and natiri start to fall in
love and as she teaches him about how
they live in harmony with nature he
starts to realize the humans are the bad
guys now the most important thing Jake
has to learn is how to ride the animals
here it's Unique because on Pandora
everything has this sort of gross nerve
tendril that can connect and like oh
mentally Bond you for Jake's final exam
they go up to the cool floating
mountains where Jake will have to ride a
pterodactyl and so Jake grabs one pulls
out his brain penis and yeah he's flying
finally learned to paint with all the
colors of the wind and by the way most
of this movie is just these gorgeous
shots which were cutting edge Graphics
in 2009 Plus in 3D so that's why the
movie was so popular so now Jake Sully
is fully accepted as one of the navi
natiri takes him down to their sacred
boning tree and these two get it on an
alien style but now the humans are sick
of waiting they start bulldozing the
sacred trees Jake tries to stop him but
it's like oh hell no clearly Jake has
lost himself his mission's over so it's
time to bust in there and blow up the
absolutely massive home tree Jake and
his friends are under arrest but
Michelle Rodriguez is here to bust him
out and fly him to a mobile lab but
during their escapes Sigourney Weaver
was shot so they're gonna try something
at the Spirit tree to permanently move
her mind into her Avatar body which is
theoretically possible because all these
Pandora plants are connected but it
doesn't work and Sigourney Weaver dies
now the navi are all mad at Jake because
he started undercover so he's got to do
something crazy to win back their trust
earlier we met an even bigger
pterodactyl they called taruk and Jake's
like well I'm gonna ride it and yes he
pulls it off becomes the legendary
figure taruk maktau he flies around to
unite all the plans and when the humans
come to bomb the Tree of Souls it's a
big Navi Army here for the final battle
and yeah the navi are incredible
Fighters but they still use bow and
arrows while humans have guns so things
aren't going well but what's this now
all the dangerous wildlife has come to
join the fight yes Pandora defending
itself their goddess AWA heard their
prayer but mean military guy is a huge
badass goes for the one-on-one with Jake
and he goes for Jake's weak spot yes his
defenseless human body that can't
breathe Pandora air but busting in to
save her boyfriend is natiri yeah it
takes this guy out against Jake's human
body and It's A Beautiful inter-species
Romance moment as even in this weird
alien body she's like I see you and so
the day is saved all the evil humans are
kicked off Pandora but you know they'll
probably be back with bigger guns as for
Jake Sully this human body just ain't
doing it for him anymore he decides to
try the Tree of Souls Perma Swap and
this time it works Jake Sully
permanently a Nabi and that's where the
first Avatar movie comes to an end
if you liked this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
Recaps of TV and movies
[Music]